from series getting renewed then
canceled and sometimes even uncanceled
2022 was a scary time to like a TV show
and that's not even mentioning the
bloodbath at HBO Max here are some of
the major shows that got the ax in 2022
the Netflix series Warrior nun which
first premiered in 2020 starred Alba
Baptista as Ava Silva an orphan who
wakes up in a morgue and realizes she
has Supernatural Powers Ava learns that
she is the chosen one and is part of the
order of the cruciform sword an ancient
cabal of warrior nuns both the forces of
Good and Evil want to use Ava's powers
and she must fight to Define her own
destiny fans of the show were compelled
by the life and death action as well as
the burgeoning relationship between Ava
and fellow nun Beatrice sadly fans
excitement about the show wasn't enough
to save it from cancellation in December
2022 it was announced that the series
would not return for season three the
decision to cancel the show is
especially puzzling considering Warrior
none has the highest audience rating on
Rotten Tomatoes of any Netflix original
women and lgbtq plus fans of the show
were especially devastated by the
cancellation as Netflix seems to have a
habit of canceling shows led by young
women and queer people following the
announcement the hashtag renew Warrior
nuns started trending on Twitter with
fans hoping that their favorite show
might be resurrected by another Network
the historical series Gentleman Jack a
co-production between HBO and the BBC
follows industrious landowner and Lister
based on lister's own prolific Diaries
the show follows her life in 1830s
Halifax while involving herself in
politics and Industry Lister also
develops a relationship with Ann Walker
a landed woman who becomes her wife and
life partner the series was especially
popular with lgbtq plus women and the
BBC even created a documentary called
Gentleman Jack changed my life we're not
alive are we
for not taking the old risk sadly these
span engagements weren't enough to save
the show and HBO announced its
cancellation in July 2022. according to
radio times series Creator Sally
Wainwright has discussed the possibility
of the series being picked up by another
network but the entire year went by with
nothing coming of it following the
cancellation fans of the show took to
Twitter using the save Gentleman Jack
hashtag and some even traveled to
analysters ancestral shibdon Hall to
participate in a flash mob according to
the Yorkshire post the series only ran
for two short seasons and considering
the fact that lister's Diaries run to
more than 4 million words there is
certainly more story to be told
there is nothing quite like the HBO
series Los spookies set in an unnamed
country in Latin America the Spanish
language series follows a group of
friends who start a horror themed
business where their job is to create
terrifying scenes for their clients the
business is run by the horror loving
Ronaldo who is joined by his best friend
and sisters the series is a hilarious
strange and surrealist comedy like no
other unfortunately HBO canceled the
series after only two seasons much to
the disappointment to fans many fans
mourned the loss of a truly unique
Latino show that did not revolve around
U.S interests TV critic Emily Nussbaum
took to Twitter to voice her
frustrations writing it was a silly
confident stylized comedy with fantastic
characters set in a highly specific Camp
queer satirical Universe it was a bit
like what we do in the shadows
swashbuckling comedy that never pandered
you'd think I'd be over shows getting
axed but it deserved three or more
seasons there are always several medical
dramas on air at any given time but none
have come close to the success of Gray's
Anatomy New Amsterdam which is based on
the book 12 patients life and death at
Bellevue Hospital struggled to achieve
longevity the series follows Dr Max
Goodwin a talented doctor who becomes
the medical director of New Amsterdam
the oldest public Hospital in America Dr
Goodwin sets out to reform the system
shaking up the outdated bureaucracy that
inhibits good medical care you sure you
got time for this I got all the time in
the world the series was celebrated for
its unique take on the medical drama
focusing more on the failures of the
institution rather than salacious drama
between doctors and their patients
however it was also regularly criticized
for its lack of subtlety the ratings for
the show were initially strong but they
began to decline leading to the show's
cancellation in 2022 per TV series
finale many fans expressed frustration
about the show's Fifth and final season
which seemingly destroyed the Beloved
romance between Max and fellow colleague
Dr Helen Sharp
the CW has long been known as the
premier home for teen television one of
its most popular shows of the 2010s was
The Vampire Diaries a dark brooding
series that capitalized on The
bloodsucker Craze of the era the series
spawned two spin-offs The Originals and
Legacies as the title suggests legacies
follows the second generation of the
characters we first met in the originals
klaus's daughter hope andalark's twins
Lizzie and Josie are students of the
Salvatore school for the young and
gifted an academy for young witches
vampires and werewolves along with
Supernatural elements fans of the show
were especially enamored with some of
its young couples as reported by
Entertainment Weekly the cancellation of
legacies marks more than just the
conclusion of a single show but of a
larger era 2023 marks the first time in
13 years that there won't be a Vampire
Diaries show on air nonetheless the
vampire craze isn't entirely over as
variety noted Creator Julie pleck is now
working on a Vampire Academy series for
peacock Netflix famously produces a ton
of content and not all of it becomes a
smash hit in the summer of 2022 it
seemed like Netflix had another winner
on its hands but a renewal was just not
in the cards first kill is a Romeo and
juliet-esque take on the vampire love
story with a Twist the series follows
Juliet a young woman Who develops
feelings for classmates Calliope the
only problem is that Juliet is a vampire
and Calliope is a Monster Hunter and
their Warren families want each other
dead fans were enamored with the show's
queer take on the vampire love story and
a bloodthirsty fan base developed right
away all I wanted to do was kiss you
despite the Rabid attention from fans
first kill was canceled less than two
months after the premiere of its first
season per deadline Time Magazine
reported that the show's cancellation
was puzzling writing although Netflix
doesn't share many of its metrics first
kill was in its Global top 10 TV list
for three weeks racking up
97.66 million hours watched in that time
alone disappointed fans were quick to
bring up the fact that queer-centric
shows are often first on the chopping
block with first kill being yet another
example of this troubling pattern
meanwhile showrunner Felicia D Henderson
told The Daily Beast that she was
disappointed in the lack of effort
Netflix put into marketing the series
something that may have led to the
show's eventual demise
the cancellation of the HBO Max series
Minx is probably the strangest one so
far the series is set in the 1970s and
follows Joyce prigger a young feminist
living in Los Angeles Joyce begins an
unlikely partnership with Doug a sleazy
publisher in order to create the first
erotic magazine for women the series was
positively reviewed by critics with many
noting that it didn't sacrifice smarts
for Laughs what makes its cancellation
so odd is that it was already renewed
for a second season when it got canceled
otter still is the fact that season 2
was almost completed when news of the
cancellation surfaced star Jake Johnson
wrote on Instagram we've been removed
from HBO Max but we're still finishing
the season so thankfully they didn't
halt production we're about a week away
from being finished shooting the
cancellation of Minx is almost certainly
another cost cutting measure on the part
of HBO Max which has been axing shows
left and right since its merger with
Discovery but there's a rare silver
lining for this series A months after
the second season was canceled it was
announced that the show was getting
picked up by stars giving all that hard
work a chance to see the light of day
look what you made it means something to
people and I didn't know what to do with
it
based on the Michael Crichton movie of
the same name HBO's Westworld was once
one of the biggest shows the platform
had to offer the series racked up an
astounding 54 Emmy nominations over four
seasons according to deadline at the
Time season one of the show was the most
watched first season of any HBO original
with an average of 12 million viewers
the dystopian series takes place at a
futuristic Western theme park run by
hosts a group of Android robots who are
programmed to allow visitors to live out
their wildest fantasies hosts memories
are wiped after each session and they're
unable to fight back until a software
update causes Two Hosts to regain their
memories and become sentient you have a
dream you're someone else despite its
status as one of HBO's most successful
shows Westworld was canceled in November
2022 following the conclusion of its
fourth season according to the Hollywood
Reporter viewership for the show
declined significantly in season three
and four and viewers found it more and
more difficult to follow the complicated
storylines in an interview with deadline
co-creator Jonathan Nolan revealed we
always planned for a fifth and final
season we are still in conversations
with the network we very much hope to
make them
there is no talk show quite like Jesus
and Marrow which is why its sudden
departure from our screens is so
disappointing hosted by Jesus nice and
the kid marrow the series is an
outgrowth of their successful podcast
Bodega boys the Bronx natives have a
unique talk show style tackling topics
like sports pop culture and politics
with an irreverent wit and off the cuff
commentary their show originally aired
on the now defunct viceland before
moving to showtime in 2019. however in
2022 it was announced that the series
would not be continuing much to the
shock of dedicated fans the end of the
series came as a surprise to many though
marrow shared on the basic podcast in
August 2022 Jesus and I had discussed
pursuing separate interests over a year
prior to the show coming to an end and
that conversation solidified Us in
signing overall agreements that
recognized our intent to operate
independent of one another
reboots are not always successful but it
seemed like peacock's New Vision 4 Saved
by the Bell might be one of the lucky
ones the series which premiered in 2020
focused on a new generation of students
at Bayside High following the governor's
order to transfer low-income students to
the prestigious School the show also
brought back several characters from the
original including AC Slater played by
Mario Lopez Jesse Spano played by
Elizabeth Berkeley and Mark Paul
gossler's Zack Morris the show was
reviewed positively by critics with the
guardian writing the reboot depicts
social issues in a way that feels
authentic and in line with the show's
tone sadly Saved by the Bell was
canceled in May 2022 much to the
disappointment the fans were frustrated
by the abrupt ending per deadline for
instance it seemed as though Jesse and
Slater were about to enter into a
relationship at the end of season 2.
meanwhile showrunner Tracy wigfield told
TV line that she wanted to bring back
Leah Remini as Stacy for season three
something we'll sadly never get to see I
mean you were right
the only way through hard things is
together
legendary focused on the queer and
trans-centric Ballroom community and
followed the format of reality shows
like Project Runway and America's Next
Top Model each season saw several teams
known as houses show off their voguing
skills and fashion designs for the
chance to win a cash prize legendary was
a joyful and important experience for
viewers and participants alike as one of
the few shows on air that centered on
the talents of queer black folks fans
were understandably upset when the
series was scrapped in December 2022
reporting on the cancellation them wrote
during a time of anti-lgbtq plus
backlash the talent behind the show said
they felt a particular urgency with the
third season to represent and support
young queer people by showcasing their
talents
fitting right in on cbs's schedule full
of crime and legal procedurals bull is
about the previously little-known world
of Jury consulting inspired by the
former career of talk show host and
executive producer Dr Phil McGraw it ran
for six seasons on CBS spending its
first two years among the top 10 most
watched programs on broadcast TV but
then on January 18 2022 lead actor
Michael Weatherly tweeted that he was
ready to leave Bull and CBS then opted
to cancel the show rather than continue
on without its anchor and besides after
six seasons the show was no longer the
ratings Juggernaut it once was ranking
as the eighth most watched CBS drama
among all viewers and dead last in the
sought after 18 to 49 demographic but I
feel confident we can turn that around
in another generation or two in January
2022 ABC launched Promised Land a
throwback to The Prime Time soap operas
of the 70s and 80s it was set at a
picturesque California Winery detailing
the machinations and romantic
entanglements of several generations of
a sprawling spoiled family alas Promised
Land brought in the lowest 18 to 49
numbers of any ABC Drama in the 2021-22
season and it lasted just five episodes
on the prime time schedule subsequent
installments were then dropped directly
on Hulu while Creator Mack Lopez claimed
on Instagram that the move didn't equal
a cancellation the low ratings and
unceremonious dumping make a second
season highly unlikely
Robert Langdon is a world-renowned
symbolist the go-to expert for finding
clues in ancient works of art and
historical artifacts to uncover
far-reaching conspiracies he's the hero
of multiple best-selling novels by Dan
Brown as well as The Lost Symbol a 2020
peacock original starring Ashley
Zuckerman as Langdon Brown's novels were
all massive best sellers and three big
screen adaptations starring Tom Hanks
earned a worldwide box office of more
than 1.4 billion dollars but each film
made less than the previous and the last
one hit theaters more than five years
before The Lost Symbol debuted so
perhaps Robert langdon's time has simply
passed in January 2022 peacock canceled
the show with a source telling variety
that the streamer and producers figured
they'd told a full story in one season
Netflix's hentified is set in East Los
Angeles as it explores the experiences
of Latinos trying to make their way in a
gentrifying neighborhood It Centers on
the Morales family as they keep their
grandfather's restaurant open pursue
their own dreams and fight against the
twin menaces of immigration officials
and gentrification despite early signs
of success including strong critical
notices hentified traded in quality over
quantity and never attracted a sizable
audience or at least not one large
enough for Netflix to justify a third
season the streamer doesn't release
specific viewership numbers for any of
its shows but according to deadline the
second and ultimately final season of
hentified never made an appearance on
the Netflix top 10. and M Martin's
beloved babysitters club books are
cultural touchstones for many readers
who grew up in the 80s and 90s and
lapped up the heartwarming stories of
tween girls small business owners in
Suburban Connecticut the books have been
adapted before but Netflix's version
that debuted in 2020 earned an outsized
amount of Praise despite this critical
success the babysitters club was
canceled in March 2022 after two seasons
in an interview with vulture Creator
Rachel shukert revealed that even though
the series pulled in solid viewership
numbers it may not have been watched in
the matter most preferable to Netflix
sugared hypothesized that the streamer
wants to devote more resources to widely
appealing shows that are immediately
binge-watched upon release and draw new
markets rather than quieter shows with a
more Niche audience but still everyone
got a little of what they needed that
day
Netflix was highly motivated to land
space force which premiered in May 2020
it marked the return to series TV for
Steve Carell and his reunion with the
office showrunner Greg Daniels in a
satire of government life during the
Donald Trump Administration Corel played
an Air Force General picked to head up
the fledgling new branch of the military
known as space force the second season
dropped in February 2022 with a new
co-showrunner and production transferred
from Los Angeles to Vancouver these
changes were undertaken to improve the
show's critical quality and Buzz as well
as to cut costs the first season was
among the most expensive shows on
Contemporary TV but the viewership
figures didn't justify such an expense
especially after April 2022 when Netflix
reported a massive subscriber loss and
endured a 55 billion dollar decline in
value within a week of that financial
disaster space force was permanently
grounded Batwoman was part of the CW's
ambitious and expansive arrowverse of
interconnected superhero shows initially
starring Ruby Rose as hero Kate Kane and
then javicia Leslie as criminal turned
Caped Crusader Ryan Wilder showrunner
Carolyn dries broke the news on Twitter
in April 2022 that the show would not be
returning for a fourth season as
reported by variety The CW might be
cleaning house of its underperforming
scripted series As It prepares for an
ownership change it's currently owned by
Warner media and Viacom CBS with nexstar
Media Group preparing to buy a majority
stake Batwoman was among the least
watched shows on the network in the
2021-2022 season averaging around 760
000 viewers a drop of 20 from the
previous frame
DC's Legends of Tomorrow follows a
rotating Crew of Young superheroes
villains and Rogues who move through
space time and the universe to prevent
apocalypses and other threats to
humanity it was part of the CW's
arrowverse which dominated the network
in the 2010s but has since been
shrinking in the upcoming 2022 to 2023
season the only shows remaining in the
franchise will be the relatively young
Superman and Lois and the Flash in its
ninth and likely final season Legends of
tomorrow was among the oldest and least
popular arrowverse shows concluding
after seven seasons and attracting fewer
viewers than the superhero shows that
survived it reportedly pulled in an
average of just 860 000 Watchers in what
wound up being its final season less
than a month after the ax fell the CW
continued to clear out its schedule and
production slate when it canceled seven
more hour-long dramas including Dynasty
Charmed 4400 Roswell New Mexico in the
dark legacies and Naomi
[Music]
countless Millennials look back fondly
on the elaborately produced kids game
show Legends of the Hidden Temple like a
mini Indiana jones-style Adventure in a
competitive format the 90s series pitted
six Duos against each other as they
rated a supposedly Ancient Temple lorded
over by a talking Stone head named Olmec
in search of a Priceless artifact like
many fondly remembered 90s shows Legends
of the Hidden Temple earned a reboot
when it arrived on the CW in October
2021. this revamped bigger budget
version boasts an elaborate set and
features grown-up contestants instead of
kids comedian Cristela Alonso hosts
while D Bradley Baker reprises the role
of Olmec who remains as eerily
impressive as ever sadly the revamped
Legends was met with historically bad
ratings as it reportedly averaged fewer
than 300 000 viewers unsurprisingly then
it was canceled in June 2022 perhaps The
Nostalgia craze that's been gripping TV
lately is finally over or maybe the new
Legends of the Hidden Temple simply
failed to recapture the original's music
the 2021-2022 season marks the 14th
Street year that CBS has been able to
call itself the most watched TV network
in the United States thus compared to
other networks it has higher and more
narrow standards of what constitutes a
hit and which shows are worthy of
renewal that was especially apparent in
May 2022 when CBS canceled one
long-running drama and three sitcoms
with middling to low viewership figures
such a culling makes way for a slew of
new series more in line with the
Network's hit crime dramas the axed
shows were be positive United States of
Al and how we roll as well as the Magnum
PI remake which was later picked up by
NBC at the same time CBS ordered three
new dramas cop show East New York Legal
Series so help me Todd and firefighter
yarn fire country so help me Todd at
least sounds like it'll be good for a
laugh every now and then but you
couldn't really call it a comedy and
that's just fine with CBs yes maybe I
should just let you be who you want to
be
one of the most visually striking sci-fi
shows in recent memory Raised by Wolves
revolves around two Androids mother and
father who are programmed to raise six
human children on a dangerous alien
planet they create a solid space Colony
but all their hard work is threatened
when a theological conflict erupts TNT
ordered Raised by Wolves back in 2018
but it would ultimately premiere on HBO
Max in 2020 both seasons of the show
earned strong reviews but the series
couldn't overcome its behind the scenes
shuffling in April 2022 Warner media and
Discovery Inc merged to form a new Media
Company Warner Brothers Discovery
according to raised by wolfstar Abu Bakr
Salim this merger brought an early end
to many Productions including the Sleek
Sci-Fi show he expressed hope however
that it might be picked up and continue
on another platform if enough fans push
for a rescue
following Nancy Drew And The Hardy Boys
the CW's Tom Swift was the latest gritty
contemporary reimagining of a
decades-old young adult novel series
Loosely based on the books that first
appeared in print in 1910 Tian Richards
portrayed the title billionaire and Tech
genius who wages war with a shadowy
global conspiracy he believes is
responsible for The Disappearance of his
father in the books Tom Swift was a
white teenage inventor while on the show
he's a gay black billionaire in his 20s
but that big change did little to grab
audiences attention the ratings were
strikingly low with a negligible 0.1
rating in the coveted 18 to 49
demographic as reported by deadline the
show's edgy content may have been what
really led to its demise as next our
Media Group is set to acquire the CW and
reportedly isn't interested in
programming that isn't squeaky clean
debuting in February 2020 Fox's
quick-witted animated family sitcom
Duncanville arrived packed with Talent
co-created by Amy Poehler and longtime
Simpsons writer Mike Scully the show
revolved around a wildly mediocre but
self-aggrandizing teenage boy named
Duncan voiced by polar a typical episode
featured him bristling against parental
control and hanging out with his crew of
near-dual friends alas Duncanville just
couldn't perform at a competitive enough
level for Fox which boasts more animated
shows in production than it has space
for on its Sunday night animation block
with established hits like The Simpsons
Bob's Burgers and Family Guy and newer
entries like housebroken and the great
North the network also had to make room
for upcoming cartoons kripopolis
produced by Community Creator Dan Harmon
and grimsberg starring Jon Hamm the
ratings for Duncanville season 3 were so
bad averaging 530 000 viewers per
episode that fox pulled it off the
schedule and at some point will dump six
unaired episodes onto Hulu ah leaving
bye why women kill is a Darkly comic
crime Anthology detailing the events
that led up to the titular murders
debuting on CBS all access in 2019 the
first season concerned three different
time periods where the same Pasadena
house and cheating were involved season
2 followed in 2021 on CBS all access
successor Paramount plus with a
standalone story about a new character
driven to commit homicide in December
2021 Paramount plus ordered a new set of
episodes of why women killed the show
reportedly placed high on a top 10 list
of the streamer's most popular and
visible programs the new slate of
episodes went into pre-production but
then on July 1st 2022 Paramount plus
reversed course and decided that it
didn't want any more why women kill
after all and canceled the series after
just two seasons thank you
[Music]